this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and today we're back with the
battlefield franchise as jonathan takes
a look at the weapons of battlefield bad
company 2.
something else that i really want to to
comment on is the
weird left-hand ejection on all of the
weapons
by and large that's not a good idea
because most of your soldiers are
right-handed
and cartridge cases flying out of the
left potentially could be a problem
if you want to see more of jonathan's
take on battlefield make sure to
subscribe so you can also check out our
videos on battlefield 4
1 and 5. if there are any other games
guns or mechanics that you guys want to
see jonathan break down let us know in
the comment section below
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
i couldn't help noticing that what
seemed like a an audio
loop effect from the firing of that
light machine gun which is the
the chinese type 88 something from from
way back in gaming
that you could always pick up on was
where there's a wav file repeating
where something is firing automatic and
there's that ever so slight break
in as the file loops i don't think
that's what's happening here i think
it's been designed to fire effectively
bursts
for some reason even though it is meant
to be automatic
i might be over analyzing but uh as
discussed that that's what i'm here for
there's a strong trend in the
battlefield games of
setting them in the near future like
5-10 years in the future something like
that
and so they they have tended to
anticipate
what will be a standard service weapon
in the near future and
i think almost invariably they get it
wrong which is no fault of theirs really
because it's to do with the um
political machinations and costs of
things and how many of an existing
perfectly good rifle that you already
have
and so the the auk 971 this is
a relatively early version that's been
depicted here with that green
almost sa-80 looking handguard on it and
that has
failed to become a standard
primary issue service rifle in the
russian armed forces but it has seen
limited adoption
so but not in this form it continued to
evolve
and i think the latest version is now
being marketed under the
chord name which is the name of a heavy
machine gun they must have tested that
and decided that it would sell better
the uzi appearing in bad company 2
we've got a reasonable representation
it's falling into the the classic trap
of depicting the weapon as closed bolt
so firing from a closed bolt rather than
with the bolt cocked to the rear
which is how the vast majority of uzis
work
and all of the select fire ones and this
is because you can see the
selector markers and markings and you
know how it works in the game but other
than that it's a decent rendition for
for the period of the classic uzi
and from memory it does kind of
underscore why you generally want an
assault rifle
because it's got limited range and
penetration
and therefore damage but it's got a
decent capability at close quarters
so it's got its place but increasingly
on the real battlefield
there's not much room for these pistol
caliber automatic weapons
submachine guns
watching this again is like a not only
like a weird nostalgic throwback because
i put a lot of hours into this a decade
ago but also like a weird
bit of firearms history as well because
the xm8 was like the great hope for a
new
family of infantry weapons and it looked
futuristic and it looked cool
and then it didn't go anywhere so this
is another
frozen in time this is what the future
could have been
moments with with battlefield which has
happened more than once
although weirdly the xm8 did see serial
production
of all armed forces the malaysian
navy has xm8 and i think they are marked
xm8 as in experimental and it's it had
an interesting interface system which is
what those
those weird socket holes are in the side
the idea was you would plug in
your accessories to those holes this was
before the picatinny rail became
truly dominant and so it had a the xm8
had its own proprietary system of
attaching
everything from the optics to lights and
lasers and grips and things like that so
a really interesting what might have
been preserved in
digital form something else that i
really want to to comment on
now that i have the platform to do so
because this used to drive me
absolutely nuts back in the day is the
weird left-hand ejection on all of the
weapons they all ejected cartridge cases
to the left
now there are one or two weapons in
existence that do that but by and large
that's not a good idea because most of
your soldiers are right-handed
and cartridge cases flying out of the
left potentially could be a problem
and although i've never spoken to a
developer i'm pretty sure i know why and
it's the same reason that the cartridge
cases kind of trickle
out of the side of the weapon in a
graceful fashion which is not realistic
either
and that's because they want to show off
the animation they want the player to be
able to see
and admire the detail that was going
into these
circa 2010 graphics and they were
impressive
at the time
we saw some um judicious use of the noob
tube there
i'm not sure the recipients would have
been overjoyed at that
and those were smoke rounds which are
used for
well in the game they're used for for
cover now the ranges we saw
there there is not sufficient arming
time because
a 40 ml grenade arms but in terms of how
many rotations it's
um described uh before it hits what it's
aimed at and at that distance there is
not sufficient distance
slash time for the thing to arm so it
would just go
funk and imagine it would hurt quite a
bit and if it hit you in the face it
would probably knock you out of the
fight but uh it wouldn't
explode in a lethal fashion of course
being a smoke around it's not meant to
be lethal
anyway but any explosive going off close
to you is
the concussion of it is potentially
going to incapacitate you regardless
as it does burst open there will be some
limited fragmentation as well
although it's designed not to do that
would it would it kill somebody
let's not find out
[Applause]
so this representation of the g3
functions a little differently than
quite a few of them i'm thinking in
particular of call of duty where
from memory it tends to be a
semi-automatic designated marksman class
weapon here it's very much as it was
originally conceived so
a an assault rifle really albeit firing
a full power cartridge
what's often called today a battle rifle
but i i reject that term it's not a
particularly meaningful term
so it's a bit too controllable so
designed as a select fire weapon
so you can fire accurate single shots or
you can
fire bursts or hold down the trigger and
dump the magazine
in reality that is completely worthless
the recoil of the g3 is significant
the intent of of that select fire
capability was really for
well yeah busting indoors jumping into a
trench
and you'd be firing it from the hip
looking where you're aiming in the
traditional
old-fashioned assault position you would
not be firing automatic from the
shoulder
the player there is doing um good
execution as i used to say
with his automatic g3 but in reality he
would struggle
except at close range
so this is pretty much the scar l that
you see in the game
and this unlike the xm8 this did enter
us service
they are still around in delta force
some other units but not the light
version this
was found to be i believe there were
reliability issues it's pretty well
modelled in the in the game
it does suffer from the weird left-hand
ejection issue the rear sight is an odd
one as well this has got the
the actual fn um back up sights
and as you can see it's an adjustable
for height
rear aperture an l-shaped tiny little
adjustable two different sizes so an
open
and a more open aperture for close range
work and
a sort of more diopter-esque one
for longer ranges and then you you twist
it to adjust the height
that's not what we see in the game we
just see a weird little stump with a
v-notch cut in it don't think that's
based on a real one i think that was
just a bit of a fudge
the usas usa s12 fully automatic shotgun
is quite well represented in the game if
i remember rightly this is one of my
go-to weapons when i was playing the
game originally 10 round
drum magazine on there it's automatic
but it's quite controllable in fact it's
so slow that you could pretty much
just make do with semi-automatic but it
is full auto it's not quite iconic
but it's got a certain um recognition
factor it's got that
weird morphed ar15 look to it with the
carrying handle and obviously it is an
ar-15 pistol grip
and this whole part of the receiver is
based on the aar
it is like a sort of cartoon m16 that
fires 12 gauge rounds
and the real gun isn't much less
ridiculous than that sounds
the mg3 makes an appearance specifically
the mg3
not a legacy mg42 although i think
people
would be surprised to know how much the
same gun those are
this one's a weird one because it's
fitted with a russian cobra red dot
sight but
hey we're meant to be the russians i
assume now in reality that sight would
not fit the
nato slash picatinny rail that you do
find on some mg3s on the top cover which
is
i guess a difference between that and
the mg42 and it's one of the only
guns in the game that feeds from the
correct side
feeds from the left ejects to the right
because it's a belt fed mg
you're seeing the um the belt of
cartridges getting fed into the gun from
the from the feed device because it's
kind of held centrally you get to see
them come out the side a bit
to the right as well as you can tell
it's a bit of a pet peeve
[Music]
so the sidearm here is actually a an m92
or m9 beretta
but the name and the icon are the m93r
the uh burst fire stablemate of the m92
um so we've got a full auto m92 i don't
remember this but um
i'm guessing they ran out of time or
changed plans or something
and i had to use a standard m9 model for
their machine pistol
it also shouldn't well look to be firing
automatic rather than burst which you
shouldn't do the m93r can only do
three-round burst as any robocop fan
knows
and then the the primary weapon there
was the big old barrett m95
not the iconic m82 m107 but the m95
which is
a ballpark so trigger in front of the
breach
and b bolt action an odd choice on the
face of it but of course it offers
built-in gameplay balance because it
slows the rate of fire down
without having to fudge it in any way so
a clever choice i think
the mg36 not a light machine gun you see
particularly often in video games
um so another eclectic choice by the
battlefield developers we've got one
behind me somewhere
that's got a rail carry handle fitted to
it this one is
depicting the bundesfare standard
configuration
except that from memory in that short
clip i've just seen
i don't think it incorporates the dual
sights that it should do
so the the bundeswear version has a
three power magnified sight and a red
dot sight and you
just raise your head up and down to use
both very good for the time or a bit
limiting later on when technology moved
on and there were better options
available
yeah it's only at this point that i
remember or
realized that the class system in in the
battlefield in this battlefield game was
a little curious the idea of the the
medic
not carrying a shorter lighter weapon
and actually carrying a longer heavier
weapon
light machine gun which i've completely
forgotten was the case is a bit
curious because um well for one thing
medics are typically armed with a
standard service rifle
there's then the practical element of
your carrying additional medical
equipment and an absolute ton of ammo
for a quite a heavy bulky
weapon so it's it's a real contradiction
that you're you're the one laying down
the hate
on the enemy with a machine gun and then
running over and
patching them up but hey you know class
systems have to work someway
all right well um i'm shortly to myself
because that was some really
well played bit of anti-tank
anti-aircraft um i find anti-tank a bit
underwhelming in a lot of video games
you really don't feel like you're doing
very much
this game um you really felt like you
were making a difference and you felt
like the sort of threat
that infantry anti-tank weapons really
do pose
to armored vehicles you know there's a
reason why tank battles are
much less a thing on the modern
battlefield ever since effective
lightweight portable shaped charge
warheads became a thing whether they're
from a recoilless weapon or a rocket
launcher you know in an urban
environment especially
you are in serious trouble if you're in
a tank it caused a you know
another arms race effectively between
explosive reactive armor bar armor
to try and keep armored vehicles in the
running because otherwise
you know any tom dick or harry with an
anti-tank weapon could take you out
and this game gave you that and it was
very satisfying to
watch that munition go in a slight arc
and chunk and you take them out
which is what we saw there and the
weapon in question was the carl gustav
which is actually quite an old design
the original design is uh immediately
post-war
1948 and it actually came out of service
certainly in the us armed forces and
then came back
in an upgraded but recognizable form
british armed forces are still using it
so yeah bit of a legend the old charlie
g
if you'd like to help us out here at the
royal armouries we've got links in the
description
one of the best ways you can help us is
to come and see us because we are open
again now if you're close enough to do
that
we've also got our own series of short
videos on
some of the objects in the collection
here so head over to the royal armouries
channel and check those out
and i'll see you again on another one of
these soon
[Music]
[Music]
you